bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
28e jour de guerre en ukraine on va
s'intéresser ce soir un autre aspect du
conflit cette guerre pourrait entraîner
une crise alimentaire mondiale un
ouragan de famine selon le secrétaire
général de l'onu antonio guterres s
l'ukraine et la russie sont les greniers
de l'europe elles constituent à elles de
15 pour cent de la production mondiale
de blé et près de 30% des exportations
avec les combats ce grenier dont coupé
du monde l'egypte la tunisie l'algérie
sont particulièrement touchées par les
pénuries et la flambée des prix mais
aussi des pays comme l'indonésie la
turquie le mali le burkina faso ou
encore le sénégal le risque d'émeutes de
la faim resurgit alors quelles sont ces
risques justement ces risques de famine
liées à la guerre en ukraine quels sont
les risques de crises alimentaires
comment les pays d'afrique se
mobilise-t-il l'europe et les etats-unis
peuvent-ils pallier le manque l'europe
doit elle aussi revoir son modèle
agricole on en discute avec mes invités
j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
alexandre kateb bonsoir économiste
spécialiste des pays émergents hauteur
des économies les économies arabes en
mouvement et c'est aux éditions de boeck
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le débat
alexandre kateb en face de vous aux gens
dans le daniel bonsoir jean marc
économiste professeur émérite à le s&p
europe auteur de histoire de l'économie
mondiale des chasseurs cueilleurs au
cyber travailleurs et sécher est à
l'envié bienvenue à vous également marc
dufumier est avec nous bonsoir à vous
agronome professeur honoraire à
agroparistech
et puis nous avons avec nous parce qu
est de bratislava
jean martin bauer chef de mission pour
le pam le programme alimentaire mondial
en slovaquie bonsoir et bienvenue
bonsoir avant de démarrer ce débat je
vous propose de faire un point en images
avec monia kacem
galettes de pain incontournable des
repas en egypte devenue aussi un
indicateur de la crise alimentaire leurs
prix ont augmenté de 25% conséquence de
l'invasion russe en ukraine car l'egypte
est le plus gros importateur de blé au
monde
et l'an dernier 70 % de ces céréales
provenaient de russie et d'ukraine
aigle et tu très précisément utilisé
dans le pain subventionné un pain qui en
fit à 80 millions d'égyptiens qui sont
inscrits sur les cartes de subventions
et donc qui
pourrait ne pas en bénéficier en
quantité suffisante ch'ti on ne trouve
pas moyen d importer du blé la russie et
l'ukraine représente à elle seule un
tiers des exportations de céréales dans
le monde avec le blocage de ses ports
l'ukraine ne peut plus exporter la
récolte de cette année est incertaine et
les sanctions prises contre la russie
devrait perturber les exportations
l'egypte n'est pas le seul pays à voir
ses réserves de céréales impacté le
kazakhstan la mongolie le liban ou
encore la turquie dépendent de la russie
et de l'ukraine à plus de 70% sur le
continent africain les craintes d'une
pénurie se font aussi ressentir en
somalie au bénin à madagascar ou encore
en république démocratique du congo en
tunisie aussi les boulangers voient
leurs stocks de farine ça me nuire les
conséquences pourraient être encore plus
grave au soudan où plus de 85% du blé du
pays provient de russie et d'ukraine
président soudanais sur deux pourrait
souffrir de la faim cette année d'ici la
fin de l'année près de 20 millions de
personnes soit près de la moitié du pays
seront en situation d'insécurité
alimentaire
une insécurité alimentaire qui va de
pair avec l'inflation déjà fragilisée
par la crise sanitaire et l'instabilité
régionale de nombreux pays africains
pourraient voir leur économie sombrer un
peu plus macky sall président sénégalais
mais aussi de l'union africaine a
demandé mardi le soutien de la banque
mondiale et des partenaires
internationaux pour faire face aux
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
jean martin bauer vous êtes chef de
mission pour le pam le programme
alimentaire mondial est ce qu'il ya un
risque d'émeutes de la faim qui
ressurgit est ce que au programme au pam
vous tirer la sonnette d'alarmé nous
tirons la semaine la situation est très
inquiétante
au niveau du programme alimentaire
mondial le bassin de la mer noire assure
50 % de nos approvisionnements donc
cette crise est aussi une crise les
approvisionnements pour les humanitaires
nous avons un surcoût à cause de la
hausse des prix que cette crise
occasionnée nos coûts ont augmenté de 71
millions de dollars par mois
si vous n'arrivez pas à mobiliser cette
somme supplémentaire c'est l'aide
humanitaire dans des pays comme le yémen
comme l'afghanistan qui est en danger
donc aide humanitaire plus tout ce dont
on a pu parler alexandre kateb la
tunisie on voit qu'elles dépendent
l'étranger pour trois quarts de ses
approvisionnements en blé quels sont les
risques de crises alimentaires au
maghreb et en égypte en particulier des
pays très exposé c'est sûr que le
premier pays le plus exposé de par la la
le volume de sa population et la
dépendance vis-à-vis des importations
c'est l'egypte évidemment
puisque ce pays dépend quasiment
entièrement du blé russe et ukrainien
pour son approvisionnement en céréales
et le gouvernement avait progressivement
réduit les subventions qui était
accordée à ces produits de première
nécessité et ses subventions vont
probablement être
remis remis sur le devant de la scène
parce que c'est vraiment une question
clé et les autorités égyptiennes le
président 6,6 en particulier ne veut
surtout pas avoir un remake du scénario
qui avait conduit au printemps arabe de
2011 suite à la crise alimentaire de
2008 avec des émeutes de la faim on va
écouter secrétaire général de l'onu
antonio guterres est ce
le plus prégnant vie un enfer vivant et
les répercussions se font sentir dans le
monde entier avec la flambée des prix
des aliments de l'énergie et des engrais
menaçant de dégénérer en une crise
mondiale de la fin d'hiver au point
quand les pays en développement
suffoquer déjà sous le fardeau du coc
vide et du manque d'accès à un
financement adéquat
maintenant ils paient aussi un lourd
tribut à cause de cette guerre resort
l'historienne l'économie que vous êtes
dans l'histoire les pénuries
alimentaires ont souvent donné justement
lieu à des émeutes de la faim est
derrière d'ailleurs à des révolutions on
a vu les révolutions arabes ah oui là
une des leçons que l'on peut tirer de
mon livre c'est le fait que les peuples
en faillite se révolte pour deux raisons
il se révolte contre des hausses
d'impôts c'était le cas de la révolution
française c'était le cas la révolution
américaine où ils se révoltent
effectivement contre ces des révoltes
prime intéressante contre la hausse des
prix
et et surtout la disparition
effectivement sur les marchés des des
biens des biens alimentaires cesser la
guerre des farines au xviiie siècle il y
avait la révolution française puis avant
il y avait la guerre des farines les
gens s'étaient révoltés avaient saccagé
des boulangeries le problème dans ce
genre de situation c'est est ce qu'il ya
comme le pense souvent la population des
gens qui spéculent des gens qui gardent
le blé et des gens qui se débrouille
pour profiter de la situation pour
augmenter leurs bénéfices ou s il ya
véritablement qu'une véritable pénurie
c'est dire que là on voit bien qu'il ya
une partie qui lie au fait que l'on peut
pas exporter le blé le blé existe mais
le véritable danger c'est si la récolte
n'a pas lieu en ukraine à ce moment là
effectivement il va y avoir un manque
absolu de blé il y aura pas uniquement
le fait que le blé n'arrive pas à sortir
d'ukraine et de russie c'est que le blé
n'existe pas alors après la dernière
remarque jeffrey sur le plan historique
c'est que la russie en 1910 était un
pays exportateur très nette de céréales
et l'union soviétique en 1988 et est le
premier importateur mondial de blé donc
à un moment donné le monde a pu se
passer du blé russe et ukrainien mais on
peut pas le faire immédiatement si on
peut pas brutalement décidé qu'on ne se
passe du blé russe ivan y ait commencé
dans les années 80 marc dufumier à
risque d'émeutes de la faim très réelle
je crois que tous les pays qui ont joué
la spécialisation sont les avantages
comparatifs
c'est à dire s'approvisionner en blé en
europe puis se spécialiser café-cacao
vanille et qui sont aujourd'hui très
déficitaire très dépendant des
importations
dans les périodes précises là en ce
moment conjoncturel willaya daury vrai
risque de ne pas penser à l'indépendance
alimentaire finale lui à des bornes en
sus de la télé non les producteurs de
mil et de sorgho du sénégal mange
aujourd'hui du riz et du pain en haïti
aussi c'est pareil donc effectivement
cette spécialisation sont les avantages
comparatifs était était une tromperie
alexandre kateb la situation devrait
être encore plus problématique dans et
pays musulmans parce qu'il va y avoir le
ramadan est une période où la
consommation de pain par exemple est
beaucoup plus forte oui tout à fait la
consommation de pain et tous les
produits dérivés du pas évidemment et
c'est une période qui dans laquelle
traditionnellement on assiste à une
hausse des prix chaque année et donc
dans le contexte actuel évidemment cette
hausse des prix traditionnel va être
décuplée et ça va ça va induire des
privations pourra les frustrations pour
un grand nombre de ménages qui se
prépare en fait à ce mois de fête
pendant toute une année et qui
économisent pour pouvoir justement
satisfaire à ces à ses rituels on va
écouter volet d'immerger l'inscrire le
président est chrétien qui s'est exprimé
devant les parlementaires français
c'était il ya quelques instants non on
va l'écouter d'ailleurs spécifiquement
sur ce risque de crise alimentaire
c'était hier parce qu'il a évoqué cette
question devant les parlementaires
italiens
les conséquences de cette guerre sont
déjà perceptibles dans de nombreuses
régions du monde et pas seulement en
europe et night of your body le pire
sera la famine qui approchera plusieurs
pays elise
jean martin bauer il parle de famine
jean volume volodymyr zelensky l'egypte
on le disait particulièrement touchés
comment les autorités égyptiennes
réagissent tel pour l'instant d'après ce
que j'ai lu elle rassure la population
elles ont lancé des appels d'offres
d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays mais ça
n'a rien donné parce que les prix sont
trop élevés
c'est en savoie c'est que la prise
alimentaire ou la terreur que nous
vivons en ukraine elle vient après deux
années très difficiles avec la pandémie
qui avait déjà de ravel et de durabilité
dans le pays la situation est d'autant
plus grave
une réponse sur le plan des
approvisionnements on va voir les
gouvernements ont cherché des
alternatives
dont sur d'autres continents peut-être
même changé le produit pour pouvoir
continuer à porter le nécessaire à la
population alors il faut savoir qu'en
egypte et s'était expliquée dans
l'exposé au début
le b et apporte le tiers des calories
consommées dans le pays et pour les 10%
les égyptiens les plus pauvres je vais
apporte plus que 40 % des calories donc
c'est ce mot c'est le jury l'enjeu ici
si le gouvernement n'y arrive pas
les plus pauvres en egypte au faire face
à une dégradation
certaines de leurs de leur consommation
alimentaire
c'est un pays où il ya déjà un enfant
sur cinq qui est en retard de croissance
pratiquement un enfant sur dix qui
en situation de
malnutrition aiguë à l'étranger sont
très élevés jean jestin les enjeux sont
très élevés alexandre kateb que peut
faire justement le gouvernement alors
vous parliez justement du gouvernement
égyptien qui tentait de re subventionner
les céréales également luc la tunisie et
l'égypte allait abattre peut-être des
animaux pour garder les céréales
justement pour les êtres humains oui
sachant que bon là ça résoudra pas le
problème puisque la consommation de
céréales est beaucoup plus importante et
son apport calorique comme ça a été
expliquée beaucoup plus important dans
ces pays que par exemple la viande qui
est un aliment plutôt réservé aux fêtes
et aux différentes occasions rituel donc
il n'ya pas de solution évidente à court
terme et lorsqu'ils recherchent
justement d'autres fournisseurs
manifestement ça ne porte pas ses fruits
basset cdc des processus qui prennent du
temps et donc là s'il ya une urgence et
face à cette urgence je crois que c'est
les ong humanitaires justement et les
organisations satellites des nations
unies qui sont les mieux placés pour
répondre à ce type de situation donc il
faut de l'aide alimentaire d'ailleurs la
banque mondiale ont déjà fait un geste
n'y a pas d'autres mécanismes jean marc
daniel qu'ils puissent se mettre en
place pour justement pallier ce manque
il ya deux niveaux de la production
globale c'est-à-dire le est ce que
l'humanité le monde bancaire ce moment
de blessés la question fondamentale
le problème n'est pas savoir où il est
produit c'est ce que globalement on en
manque alors c'est oui ou c'est non et
on risque d'en manquer si la récolte
n'est pas au rendez vous mais pour
l'instant on ne manque pas et surtout il
faut bien voir que des enjeux c'est
indépendamment de la guerre russo
ukrainienne les deux grandes agriculture
mondiale qui sont l'agriculture open
l'agriculture américaine c'est en train
de se réorienter avec des objectifs de
moindres productions en double d'une
production moins polluantes avec un
enjeu tier de sauver la planète et non
pas de sauver immédiatement la récolte
de l'année on va y revenir mais sur les
sur les enjeux je dirais des enjeux
financiers effectivement la banque
mondiale dès 2020 avait noté qu'il y
avait quand même un certain nombre de
pays qu'elle appelle les pays à cvc dans
les pays fragiles en situation de
conflit c'est à dire en citations guerre
et violent dans lequel il ya d une
violence sociale interne préville très
forte et elle attiré l'attention sur la
nécessité de venir en aide à ces pays
donc là dessus et le secrétaire général
des nations unies a dit il ya eu la
pandémie est donc pour l'instant les
seules initiatives qui ont été prises
c'est ce qu'on appelle les ssd c'est à
dire l'initiative de suspension du
service de la dette pour un certain
nombre de pays dont l'indonésie dont
vous parliez qui est président du g20 en
plus donc qui est un pays qui met en
avant systématique entre indépendance
également
et donc effectivement il va y avoir une
réponse financière qui va se mettre en
place le fmi a augmenté ses dotations un
peu plus de 600 milliards de dollars de
dts plus exactement donc il va y avoir
des solutions financières mais je pense
qu'un moyen long terme de la question
qui se pose c'est est ce que l'humanité
va être un capacité de produire
régulièrement suffisamment de quoi se
nourrir et d'éviter ces crise brutale
est ce que enfin une guerre entre la
russie et l'ukraine je dis pas que c'est
un événement banal mais enfin je veux
dire hélas il ya des guerres et donc ça
posant la question de l'indépendance et
surtout de l'ensemble de l'humanité
c'est à dire qu'il faut que tout le
monde de produits simples et non mais
est ce que au niveau mondial on aura
assez de blé c'est ça la vraie question
à marc dufumier j'ai également vu qu'il
ya des conséquences en europe alors bon
on parle pas de famine en europe il ya
l'impact par exemple sur l'huile de
tournesol dont l'ukraine manifestement
fournit la moitié des besoins mondiaux
est pratiquement au même la très grande
majorité de l'huile de tournesol en
europe il ya également de pénurie
d'engrais on a vu déjà des
manifestations en espagne là aussi le
problème c'est la dépendance alimentaire
la dépendance agricole so lu ment la
spécialisation excessive d agriculture à
l'échelle mondiale leur n'oublions quand
même pas qu'à pléthore de nourriture
mais qui nourrit du bétail même des
herbivores se nourrissent de grains et à
une compétition entre l'alimentation du
bétail et l'alimentation humaine c'est
la pauvreté de pays pauvres qui ont été
un peu trompé par cette spécialisation
sur les zonages par hâtif qui est à
l'origine de telles fins et de telle
disette aujourd'hui en période de crise
en particulier alors en france la
question effectivement devient que les
peut-être que les céréaliers peuvent se
réjouir un peu de voir pouvoir exporter
un prix très élevé leurs céréales mais
les éleveurs qui élèvent leurs cochons
leurs volailles et même parfois des
herbivores avec des grains eux aussi
vont souffrir donc à une vraie crise je
pense que dans toutes les agricultures
du monde on a intérêt plutôt à jouer là
diversification des productions les
interactions d'ailleurs et vous parliez
les engrais azotés de synthèse nous
sommes très dépendants pour produire du
blé de l'importation de gaz naturel
russe pour fabriquer des engrais azotés
de synthèse l usine de toulouse a
explosé il ya plus de gaz de lacq
énergies fossiles on importe aussi des
engrais azotés donc coûteux en énergie
fossile donc ça faut abandonner mon
pourrait avec une moindre dépendance des
importations de soja en provenance du
brésil fertilisez nos sols avec des
légumineuses - avoir a besoin d'utiliser
des engrais azotés de synthèse et
produire peut-être des rendements un peu
moindre en temps ordinaire était-il
nécessaire pour la france d'exporter
vers l'algérie l'egypte les prix en
compétition avec l'ukraine et la russie
ne fallait-il pas plutôt produire
peut-être un peu moins mais mieux et y
compris pour les brésiliens importé
moins de soja permettre aux brésiliens
bon de manger le soja plus tôt quand on
veut parler de la stratégie de la pac de
l'union européenne parce que vous dites
vous parler effectivement de stratégie
alors il y avait vraiment tout un tout
un débat avant cela justement jean marc
jean martin bauer l'âge et la banque
africaine de développement dont va
également lever un milliard de dollars
d'après ce que j'ai lu pour justement
augmenter rapidement les surfaces
cultivées et répondre en partie aux
pertes des récoltes donc c'est ce que
vous attendez vous des aides en fait des
gros bailleur
ddd banques donc comme la banque
africaine de développement ou encore le
fmi ou est ce que vous attendez plus du
côté américain et européen est-ce qu'ils
doivent se mobiliser pour aider en
particulier les pays pauvres les pays
occidentaux tout le monde doit se
mobiliser mais une mobilisation pour
apporter des ressources pour produire
plus d'alimentation n'est pas forcément
la solution
ce qu'il faut surtout ce sont des
investissements dans les systèmes de
protection sociale dans ces pays
vulnérables c'est-à-dire des systèmes
qui permettent aux ménages les plus
démunis d'avoir suffisamment d'argent
pour pouvoir acheter leur alimentation
une alimentation saine et nutritive
en plus de tout ce qui a été dit sur la
production il faut qu'il y ait ce volet
de protection sociale
c'est peut être des transferts
monétaires
des transferts de nourriture donc ciblé
s'appelle des programmes de cantines
scolaires ça peut être un a pris au
petit producteur du pays
et
des chiens loups du tout agricole on ne
va pas résoudre les crises alimentaires
en produits en produisons uniquement qu
on puisse plus de bus de blé
paradoxalement il faut aller plus loin
et avoir des mesures ciblées vers ces
catégories sociales les plus vulnérables
marc dufumier l'europe peut-elle pallier
les manques la france exporte un quart
du blé hors d'europe face à cette
pénurie le ministre de la culture de
l'agriculture julien de normandie appelé
l'union européenne à prendre le relais
de l'ukraine il dit qu'il faut que
l'europe produise plus elle doit assumer
sa mission de nourissier alors vous
parliez justement de cette réforme de la
pac donc l'idée là ça serait de faire en
sorte que des terres en jachère par
exemple deviennent des terres plus
rapidement cultivables c'est à dire
qu'il faut cultiver plus est ce que
c'est ça la solution dans ce cas annonce
assez contradictoire avec justement le
programme européen actuel oui dans le
strict immédiat effectivement elle se
portait du blé et leur permettre d'y
avoir accès ça paraît à peu près
raisonnable en temps ordinaire sur
produire du blé pour l'exporter vers les
pays du sud concurrencer ceux qui
produisent du mil du sorgho pour les
appauvrir les renvoyer dans les
bidonvilles et faire en sorte que ces
gens là soient pauvres et demandé un
programme d'assistance sociale alors ça
en temps ordinaire tout surtout pas
faire ça dans le strict et médias ok oui
produire et exporter davantage parce
qu'il ya un besoin immédiat peut-être
d'ailleurs que à très court terme ce
sera un peu à l'argentine de faire ça
parce que hémisphère sud vont aller dans
les semis et bénéficier des eaux prix
donc je pense qu'il va y avoir une plus
grande offre de céréales en provenant
l'hémisphère sud parce que des gens vont
vouloir bénéficier de prix élevés c'est
peut-être eux qui vont pallier en
premier certes insuffisances mais en
temps ordinaire il nous faut être très
clair il ne faut surtout pas vouloir à
tout prix exporter des blés avec des
arrêts clés pelure subventionné pour que
les gens là bas puissent être condamnés
à migrer vers les bidonvilles et re
vivre dans la pauvreté sur mark daniels
quand on n'est pas en train remettre en
question la stratégie européenne de la
pac justement qui était une stratégie
plus verte donc avec une production
moindre en tout cas moins intensive et
contradictions aujourd'hui entre cette
nécessité d' indépendance alimentaire et
en même temps de faire une agriculture
plus c'est l'impact est telle qu'elle a
été réformé au fur et à mesure que le
temps a passé et passer d'une époque où
effectivement au tout début on
considérait que l'europe avait besoin de
produire davantage parce qu'elle était
en manque la pac d'origine il fallait
augmenter la production pour faire face
aux besoins de la population européenne
qui ensuite elle a été progressivement
vers 10 entre guillemets on est arrivé à
la stratégie habituelle qu'on appelle
ftf
femmes to form to work et donc donc où
l'objet c'est effectivement de réduire
la production d'améliorer la qualité et
de faire en sorte que cette production
sera la moins pénalisante pour
l'environnement or on s'aperçoit
effectivement qu'on est quand même dans
une situation où réduire la production
sa soeur tout fait qu'il y avait un
besoin purement quantitatifs de la
population on a le même problème en ce
moment avec l'inde c'est dire que le
gouvernement maudit allait engager un
certain nombre de réformes pour essayer
effectivement à la fois d'améliorer les
rendements mais aussi d'augmenter la
qualité le type de produits il a été
obligé de renoncer sous un double
contrainte des paysans qui réclame qu'on
maintienne des prix élevés qu'on leur
reste produire beaucoup et et qui se
déclarent dans l'immédiat incapable
d'assumer des réformes sur le type de
nouvelles productions qu'on veut leur
faire faire par des fumées donc c'est il
ya une contradiction entre une
agriculture plus verte et une
agriculture et une indépendance
justement alimentaire il ya une totale
contradiction il est clair que le plus
urgent pour nous c'est peut-être pas
produire de toujours davantage humble et
à 90 quintaux très coûteux en engrais
azotés de synthèse très dépendants du
gaz naturel russe est très émetteurs de
protoxyde d azote principales
contributions l'agriculture française au
réchauffement climatique produire un peu
moins mais fertiliser les blés les
céréales en question en rotation avec
des légumineuses qui vont fertiliser le
sol en azote par la voie biologique nous
éviter des importations de soja nous
éviter ses importations de gaz naturel
russe ou d'engrais azotés de synthèse et
permet aux brésiliens de manger leur
soja ou nettement c'est plus raisonnable
mais c'est tous les peuples du monde qui
ont intérêt à diversifier l'agriculture
rotation longue et la biodiversité c'est
pas que des petites jachère je voulais
tout de suite pour la biodiversité on
remettrait des légumineuses dans nos
champs retrouverait nous en france notre
souveraineté protéinique et bien
effectivement on aura une plus grande
biodiversité - d'utilisation de produits
pesticides moins besoin d'avoir recours
au pétrole russe mais marc dufumier
est-ce qu'on a la pression tout de même
qui a tout d'une réflexion autour de la
pac en europe et aujourd'hui finalement
chacun a l'air surpris de notre
dépendance y compris donc dans les
engrais de pays effectivement qui
peuvent du jour au lendemain mais être
en guerre écoutez moi ça fait plus de 30
35 ans que je publie sa donc cette
surprise là de voir parce que
effectivement le plan protéinique j'ai
entendu c'était au lendemain du g7 à
biarritz où j'entends le président
macron nous dire il nous faut pas signé
par ratifier l'accord du mercosur en
l'état mais ça fait deux bêtes depuis
longtemps qu'il nous faut changer
complètement notre rythme en retour
beaucoup plus diversifiée beaucoup plus
respectueux de l'environnement beaucoup
moins d 1 des beaucoup moins dépendante
de ces énergies fossiles mais les
solutions les connais jean marc daniel
est ce que ce n'est pas la part d'ombré
de la mondialisation finalement 7 ce
manque d'indépendance alimentaire qu'on
retrouve même en europe l'europe qui est
tout de même la première puissance
agricole mondiale me semble utile non je
pense d'abord il est vain de penser
qu'un pays peut être totalement
autosuffisant totalement en autarcie est
d'ailleurs à l'origine de la
mondialisation c'est que l'origine du
libre-échange c'était sur le blé quand
les anglais ont libéré leur le commerce
et baisser les bras doivent essayer sur
le blé il apportait du blé des états
unis et de la france qui était à
l'époque leurs deux ennemis structurel
c'est à dire pour un anglais l'ennemi
complet total de 1820 c'est le français
et l'américain donc le véritable enjeu
dans tout ça encore une fois c'est de
faire en sorte que la spécialisation
soit la moins polluante la moine
destructrice de la nature l'enjeu
maintenant c'est moins à mon avis le
retour sur la production domestique que
la capacité de tout ces agricultures à
intégrer l'enjeu climatique
alexandre kateb là les pays arabes dont
font face à cet assaut risques de famine
est ce que vous vous pensez qu'on
pourrait assister à nouveau à des non
seulement des émeutes de la faim mais du
coup à un impact même qu'ils puissent
être politique
fautif est ce qu'on peut faire une élève
un parallèle avec 2008 et comprendre que
ces pays dans la région afrique du nord
et moyen orient plus généralement sont
confrontés aux mêmes défis que les
autres pays c'est à dire à l'équation
qui semble aujourd'hui très difficile
entre les contraintes environnementales
et les contraintes agricoles et
alimentaires si vous regardez
historiquement par exemple l'arabie
saoudite était un exportateur net de
céréales dans les années
1980 c'était un des premiers
exportateurs de céréales au monde
ailleurs des céréales qui poussait dans
le désert avec évidemment une un bilan
catastrophique du point de vue
environnemental mais c'est là où on voit
la complexité de ces sujets je pense que
il ya un don qu'ils ont changé ils
ont changé radicalement de modèle parce
qu'il pouvait aussi se permettre
d'importer
l'autre variable c'est la technologie
dont on n'a peut-être pas à parler c'est
à dire ce qu'on appelle la révolution
verte qui s'est produit dans un certain
nombre de régions du monde notamment en
amérique latine et en asie du sud et du
sud est mais à la région afrique du nord
moyen orient on n'a pas vraiment connu
cette révolution verte qui avait permis
d'augmenter les rendements notamment à
travers les nouvelles technologies les
nouvelles semences jusqu'aux ogm qui ont
aujourd'hui mauvaise réputation mais qui
font également partie de la solution si
on considère ça dans un cadre plus
général d'où cette dépense de l'egypte
par exemple nous fait gagner l'egypte
est exactement il ya des terres fertiles
l'egypte est un des pays les plus
fertiles mais et les rendements de blé
par exemple en egypte centre est
supérieur à la moyenne dans toute la
région mais le problème c'est que
l'egypte également un problème
démographique est un problème de
croissance démographique et même avec
ses rendements à l'hectare qui sont très
importants l'egypte n'arrive pas à
nourrir sa population qui représente 100
millions d'habitants aujourd'hui qui
pourrait représenter jusqu'à 150
millions d'habitants d'ici vingt ou
trente ans jean martin brière on peut
justement en redouter à la fois des
mouvements sociaux et qui ont peut-être
des qui pourrait avoir des répercussions
politiques dans ces pays là il faut s'y
attendre il faut être prêt à pouvoir
travailler avec les gouvernements pour
parer au plus pressé
c'est à dire le mettre en place les
programmes de soutien immédiat abreu
justement les personnes dans le besoin
puissent s'alimenter
mais si on regarde ce qui s'était passé
en 2008 2009 2010 2011 on se rend compte
que une augmentation des prix surtout
internationale peut se traduire par une
instabilité et nous devons nous poser la
question à l'avenir de du risque
alimentaire qui existent au niveau de
nos sociétés il ya changement climatique
il ya la pression démographique
il ya eu les impacts sur les ressources
en eau qui font que nous sommes
rencontrés dans un monde très dangereux
et les nations unies et les
gouvernements du monde doivent
travailler ensemble pour pouvoir gérer
ce risque au mieux et
c'est un enjeu qui est plus compliqué
qu'il était par le passé
de 3 ans et plus compliqué parce qu'à
plus de crise
il ya des crises qui se répète donc
celle de 2007-2008 avait est intervenue
après de longues années de stabilité sur
les marchés internationaux les années
80-90 ça a été finalement assez calme en
2007 2008 on a une première crise qui a
été un électrochoc un groupe ou pour
nous tous
suivi du présent en 2010 2011 suivi des
printemps arabes nous nous voici à alors
la crise du colis de 19 à la pandémie de
deux ans qui avait réussi à beaucoup
perturbé les marchés alimentaires
notamment les chaînes
d'approvisionnement international et
nous voilà 2022 avec une nouvelle triste
et elle se répète elles se suivent et
nous avons à faire nous revient de de
pouvoir mieux les gérer et de prévenir
les familles est de plus en plus de
crise justement il va falloir faire face
donc à une gare en ukraine mais c'est
vrai que 2008 il y avait eu une
explosion des prix on se souvient à
l'époque aussi un de des matières
alimentaires et matières premières et
finalement on ne s'adapte pas il n'y a
pas de réponse à ce type de crise on est
dans un cycle à chaque fois oui et donc
dans les crises maintenant il ya le
dérèglement climatique le réchauffement
climatique global c'est un dérèglement
climatique c'est une fréquence et une
intensité accrue des accidents
climatiques extrêmes ça peut arriver en
ukraine ça peut arriver en russie ça
peut arriver dans beaucoup de pays
effectivement les pays qui sont les plus
dépendants pour les produits de première
nécessité quand même les calories les
protéines pour l'alimentation humaine
vivent très durement ces crises donc on
n'est pas à l'abri de nouvelles émeutes
de la faim dans un très grand nombre de
pays absolument son mari daniel une
multiplication de ces crises et donc et
on n'arrive pas à y faire face oui
encore dans ses mouvements et danser
crise il ya l'aspect production il ya
l'aspect prix et dans l'aspect prix il
n'est grande caractéristique de ce qui
s'est passé notamment sur les dernières
années c'est des évolutions du taux de
change très violentes qui ont fait que
l'augmentation des prix sur le marché
international a été sur des surcompensé
sur augmenté par l'évolution du taux de
change c'est ce qui s'est passé
récemment turquie c'est ce qui se passe
en ce moment donné si est donc un des
paramètres aussi c'est d'arriver à
stabiliser les taux de change dans
certain nombre de pays qui ont des
déficits de balance des paiements
courants très très important et qui
n'arrive pas à redresser leur situation
le cas de l'égypte est très intéressant
parce que comme on l'a dit l'egypte
c'étaient le grenier à blé de l'empiré
romain s'étend une des terres les plus
fertiles sur le plan agricole de toute
la région or l'egypte un déficit de sa
balance des paiements courants qui est
liée au problème du tourisme qui était
une de ses recettes traditionnelles et
tient lui aussi à une perte d'efficacité
de son appareil productif qui fait que l
n'importe pas que du blé elle importe
beaucoup de choses et elle est en
situation d'une économie qui est une
économie qui de toute façon guère ou pas
guerre sera et apparemment durablement
en déficit exemple khattabi que peut
faire le gouvernement égyptien du coup
voir le gouvernement égyptien comme tous
les autres gouvernements de la région en
fête doivent intensifier leur
coopération parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui peuvent être réglées en
commun notamment avec les riches voisins
du golf de la péninsule arabique qui ont
les moyens financiers
et l'egypte de son côté et pays du
maghreb ont des ressources humaines en
fait qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
complètement sous-exploité et à ce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est vraiment mobilisé
toutes ses ressources tous ces talents
notamment ses ingénieurs ses
scientifiques pour imaginer des
solutions qui sont adaptées au climat de
la région adaptées aux sols de la région
et a toutes les caractéristiques
institutionnelles alors ça a commencé à
être au fait il ya des initiatives en
arabie saoudite aux émirats mais ça
reste à une échelle relativement modeste
aujourd'hui
c'est très important je pense
qu'effectivement le capital humain était
important ce sont des pays qui ont un
capital humain qui est élevé parce que
des niveaux de formations se sont
considérablement améliorées et qui n
dépendamment de l'agriculture n'ont pas
su utiliser ce capital humain pour en
faire effectivement une force de
production une force d'exportation une
force de retour à l'équilibré donc ils
sont dans une crise permanente de
déficit de alain ces paiements courants
de devises qui s'effondre et à ce moment
là de prix notamment de des matières
agricoles qui n'arrêtent pas d'augmenter
marc dufumier vous êtes d'accord ce
déficit de la balance des paiements la
balance l'extérieur provient de cette
spécialisation sur les avantages
comparatifs qui était très trompeuse il
faut être clair a expliqué la
spécialisation pour origine et audi nous
regarde vous êtes en côte d'ivoire pour
des gens qui produisait du manioc de
l'igname et ce genre de choses on a dit
plutôt que devoir continuer de
travailler à la main exporter du café et
du cacao vers des pays qui ne produiront
pas ces produits-là et acheter vos
calories alimentaires et vos protéines à
l'étranger est en fait la côte d'ivoire
l'a fait évidemment le cameroun d'autres
pays etc et tous les pays ont commencé à
spécialiser sur leurs avantages
comparatifs au point que la
surproduction de café cacao et autres ne
rémunère pas plus que le manioc l'igname
ou la banane plantain résultat c'est que
quand il ya une crise sur le blé comme
en ce moment ils se retrouvent ils se
retrouvent à exporter du café du cacao
sans pouvoir acheter effectivement de
quoi manger alors que les prix sont
devenues très élevées n'importe quoi et
du café du cacao est aussi en train
d'exploser alors qu'est et je signale
que la balance extérieure
côte d'ivoire est en train de rejoindre
l' équilibre l'enjeu c'est pas une
spécialisation l'enjeu agricole l'enjeu
c'est une capacité globalement justement
à se spécialiser là où on a vraiment des
avantages comparatifs et quand on a
fouillé mais ça augmente la dépendance
sur les autres cantons a formé une
population au niveau on peut générer la
dépendance des autres par rapport aux
produits autres que l'on fabrique c'est
à dire que lorsqu'on a une puissance
industrielle qui vous permet
effectivement de vous insérer dans les
marchés à ce moment là encore une fois
je reviens en bretagne qui a acheté du
blé aux français dans 1820 parce qu'elle
leur vendait de l'acier est donc en les
gîtes vendra des machines-outils du
savoir faire elle pourra acheter du blé
pour acheter du blé sauf que lorsqu'il
ya effectivement pénurie un problème
l'ancienne guerre mais c'est pas pour
les deux spécialisations c et de
quantités produites elles étaient
produits alimentaires un problème de
régime alimentaire aux liens qui a été
évoqué parce que ces pays présentent
comme l'egypte par exemple un aliment de
base c'était le haricot c'était le
haricot égyptien le qu'on appelle le
full et en fait il ya toute une
mythologie une culture populaire à
autour de ça le blé a porté ses venues
avec un prix du pain qui étaient
excessivement subventionnés et qui a
encouragé des pratiques de gaspillage et
de malnutrition en fait lié à ces
politiques de subventions qui ont été
détournés de leur objectif initial donc
il en fait des effets pervers
non pas de la spécialisation c'est des
effets pervers de choix effectivement
qui sont des choix erronés mais pas les
choix de spécialisation d'insertion dans
le commerce international c'est des
choix qui ont été faits par des
autorités politiques d'ailleurs amartya
sen ses écrits de remarquables texte sur
la les famines il explique but quand
gerry nobel de l'économie les familles
ne sont pas liées au fait t'as des
manques de production ni à d insertion
sur le marché international de
l'agriculture mme à des distorsions dans
les prix imposés par les pouvoirs
publics marc dufumier êtes d'accord avec
ce vieil argent leurs élèves c'est pas
une question de spécialisation de paille
vous mettez une femme qui repique du riz
à la main et son sac de riz vendu sur le
marché international en compétition avec
sac de riz qui vient de l'arkansas ces
rapports de productivité de 1 à 200 il
ya 200 fois plus de travail agricole
dans chaque de riquet terre et par cette
femme malgache qui repique à la main que
dans le sac concurrents et pour acheter
quelques produits de première nécessité
des médicaments road elle va devoir
vendre son riz au même prix alors
qu'elle a travaillée 200 fois plus elle
accepte une rémunération 200 fois
moindre c'est ça la pauvreté dans les
pays du sud et c'est ça qui fait que dès
qu'il ya un manque de nourriture et bien
effectivement on est obligé de faire un
programme alimentaire aligne mondiale on
est obligés de subventionner les choses
le le budget de l'état ne suffit pas et
c'est la déroute donc ça c'est lié à
cette spécialisation mais c'est joliment
des échanges choix de la spécialisation
vous avez raison pour la responsabilité
des pouvoirs publics qui ont opté pour
une spécialisation
outrancière et en oubliant les produits
de toute toute première nécessité et
jean martin bauer vous êtes d'accord
je compte bien faire la distinction
entre les crises agricoles une crise
alimentaire c'est pas forcément la même
chose là en ce moment on a une crise
agricole qui menace de devenir une crise
alimentaire de 60 ou latéral avoue t on
parler d'amartya sen et ses travaux au
sujet de l'accès à l'alimentation et
sarah au delà de la production c'est
certainement lié à l'accès et au système
qui ont été mises en place au niveau de
chaque pays et notamment ses systèmes de
protection sociale
qui ont fait que les gens qui en ont
besoin puissent échapper à l'insécurité
alimentaire et donc si on parle de crise
alimentaire on doit parler des systèmes
qui existent au niveau de chaque pays
pour éviter de l'insécurité alimentaire
et pas uniquement de la production un
mois avec 104 sur la tunisie pour être
un peu plus concret manifestement pays
aussi très très dépendants là il y
aurait aussi un risque d'instabilité
politique fort en tunisie en particulier
oui enfin de la tunisie c'est un pays
qui est très dépendant effectivement
pour sa consommation en énergie et en
alimentation des importations et c'est
un pays qui ont visité la fois à la
communauté internationale par l'europe
et le fmi notamment et donc
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est un pays
qui est sous tutelle d'un point de vue
économique en fait
et il faut que les tuteurs de ce pays
prennent leurs responsabilités à savoir
le les organisations internationales et
l'europe qui doivent effectivement
continuer à soutenir la tunisie n'est
pas d'autre choix mais pas d'autre choix
pour les tunisiens autre aspect est
également abordée c'est l'aspect
géopolitique on voit par exemple que
l'algérie manifestement se rapprocherait
de la france maintenant alors qu'on est
en pleine crise diplomatique justement
parce qu'elle fait face à 70 intéressant
oui parce qu'en fait il enterre dans
quelques années une brouille
diplomatique qui s'est installé entre la
france et l'algérie et à l'issue de
cette brouille en fait l'algérie avait
réorienté ses achats de céréales vers la
russie l ukraine est réputé avoir un
bled moindre qualité mais à un prix plus
compétitif que le blé français est
aujourd'hui à un rétropédalage parce que
évidemment ce pays voit bien que il peut
pas dépendre de fournisseurs a aussi
instable que ça donc ils se dirigent
vers la france en ce moment il ya une
sorte de rapprochement entre alger et
paris sur cette question believe qui
continuent d'acheter des armements à la
russie et ça c'est un autre débat mais
dont s'est dotée d'une stratégie d'
équilibre dans le cadre de relations
multipolaire et jean-martin moyenne
aspects géopolitiques justement dans
cette guerre autour du blé aussi filtrer
juste fait l'algérie et l'egypte
d'ailleurs acheté en ukraine et en
russie parce que leur blé là-bas ukraine
et russie était plus compétitive que le
nôtre nous humbles et à 70 90 quintaux
chez nous et très coûteux dans ces
engrais produits chimiques n'étais pas
compétitif à la limite c'est ce surplus
là que nous avons exagéré exporter vers
l'union européenne et un marché solvable
c'était logique mais vouloir être
compétitif avec l'ukraine et la russie
en temps ordinaire était une erreur il
nous aurait fallu plus tôt libérer des
terrains pour mettre des légumineuses je
reviens encore là dessus on l'a un peu
oublié alors aujourd'hui en état de
crise effectivement c'est à dire parler
de qualitatif c'est ça vous voulez dire
un taux compétitif dans ce que vous avez
en ukraine et en russie les rendements
sont bien moindre que chez nous la ferme
effet dix mille hectares
alors que chez nous elle fait 100
hectares évidemment le matériel est
amortie pour trois fois rien d'ailleurs
la grande ferme ukrainienne elle est
peut-être dirigée par un français ou un
allemand faut pas se tromper et donc le
blé compétitif il épate l'eau rendement
le plus élevé est au courant en intrant
chimique le plus élevé donc sur le
marché mondial effectivement la
momentanément on va pouvoir exporter
vers l'algérie l'algérie sera bien
contente qu'on puisse y exporter du blé
j'en conviens mais le temps ordinaire
c'est pourquoi en algérie encore autant
de terrains en jachère par exemple et
pourquoi on ne parvient pas à cultiver
suffisamment de céréales et légumineuses
n'est pas une révolution verte en indien
l'algérie en fête a connu une période un
peu de crise agricole qui était lié au
mode de gestion socialiste de ce secteur
et dans les années 2010 il ya eu un
virage vers un verre un mode beaucoup
plus libérale avec l'octroi de
concessions à des acteurs du secteur
privé qui ont fait s'est traduit par un
par un boom de la de la production
agricole et on n'en parle pas beaucoup
mais c'est possible que l'algérie
devienne en fait un exportateur net de
céréales et de produits agricoles d'ici
une dizaine d'années donc ils ont fait
un choix la différence est justement de
devenir indépendant d'un point de vue à
lille ans ont fait le choix de
libéraliser le fonctionnement de
l'agriculture c'est ça qui fait que
effectivement on est d'une part elle
dépendra où vous nous proposez nous nous
spécialiser en fait dans les
légumineuses
spécialistes toujours quelque chose on
est ne serait ce que parce que le climat
c'est ici qu'il ya des choses qu'on peut
produire certaines pride a pas d'autres
endroits et sur le plan géopolitique la
redistribution qui est en train de faire
est une redistribution la russie se
rapproche de la chine sera proche de m
in faith deux blocs qui est en train de
se constituer quand on parle des engrais
et tout ça les engrais manque pour des
raisons de sanctions c'était assez parce
que nous voulons pas les acheter à la
biélorussie les anglais c'est pour ça
qu'on manque d'ingrédients sous moi mais
il n'y a pas de problème de pénurie
d'anglais d'encre et en tant que tel en
ce moment jean martin a beau faire il ya
effectivement tout cette logique
géopolitique autour de cette question à
la fois de crise alimentaire est
également agricole
exacte et le risque qu'on a tué c'est
qu'on privilégie les approches min min
latéral purement bilatérale d'un pays à
l'autre pour gérer cette crise on avait
vu en 2008 2007 2008 des interdictions
d'exporter qui ont été prises par des
pays qui ont aggravé la situation est ce
que les nations unies devraient bien
voir c'est un renforcement de la
coopération
lui dit latéral pour pouvoir gérer ce
problème pour qu'il n'y ait pas des
gagnants et des perdants dès qu'on
essaye de mini minimiser les impacts ont
travaillé ensemble et fakaté bien échec
du multilatéralisme sur cette question
agricole en fait quand on regarde la
crise de 2008 déjà à l'époque on parlait
d'une régulation du prix des produits
agricoles au niveau 6 a très bien là
avec le président sarkozy notamment qui
en avait fait un peu son cheval de
bataille mais finalement tout ça a
échoué parce que les logiques du marché
les logiques de la financiarisation et
est beaucoup plus puissante que les
initiatives qui avait été prise par les
états et que c est a finalement sous le
poids de différents intérêts divergents
ont préféré enterrer enterré le sujet et
aujourd'hui ce sujet a ressurgi et je
pense que au delà d'un échec du
multilatéralisme c'est un échec du multi
l'arrêté l'arrière estime tel qu'il a
été conçu avec des organisations
distinctes qui traite chacune d'un sujet
par exemple vous avez alors mc qui
traite du commerce lifeco qui traite de
l'agriculture l'om est ce qui traite de
la santé multitude à ces organisations
ne se parlent pas je pense que l'échec
il est là c'est la solution c'est
d'organiser une meilleure coordination
une meilleure transversalité parce que
toutes ces questions on voit bien
qu'elles sont dits multi dimensionnelle
et qu'on peut pas les traiter isolément
les unes des autres jean marc daniel ses
échecs du multilatéralisme je pense que
c'est l'échec de la bureaucratie
multilatéral oui mais je pense qu'il ya
une multilatéralisme qui s'est mis en
place c'est dire que on parle gérez-vous
libéraliser le système immédiatement il
ya des gens qui se battent à produire
qui se mettent à échanger qui vont ceux
qui se rencontrent les uns les autres et
donc en revanche si vous créez une
bureaucratie qui va mettre en place des
stocks et ça regardez sur la aussi sur
l'union européenne on a connu une
période où il y avait le beurre des
interventions savais pas quoi faire du
beurre et à la fin de l'année la
communauté européenne on vendait son
beurre maintenant manque de beurre on
est en situation de pourquoi parce qu'on
n'a pas été de modifier la politique
agricole commune vis-à-vis du de la
production de lait donc il ya un moment
où il faut dire on arrête de donner des
directives et on laisse spontanément les
gens les paysans ses clopes celui qui
est là le prix nobel d'économie le seul
à avoir eu le prix nobel d'économie pour
des problèmes à l'école il s'appelait
théodore schulz disait que la grande
faiblesse des politiques agricoles c'est
de ne pas assez s'appuyer sur
l'intelligence des paysans
complètement le point de vue l'om c'est
et résout les questions des changes
agricole le la coop 21 où les coptes qui
parle d'environnement de biodiversité de
réchauffement climatique est une
organisation qui n'existent pas vraiment
réguler les mouvements migratoires mais
je suis désolé il faudrait que toutes
ces négociations l'aï lieu dans une même
en une même univers et démocratique on
est bien d'accord mais il faut mais ça
veut dire quoi à nonu de l'alimentaire
non mais en main alors est ce que ce
sera un g20 g7 et otc gouvernance
mondiale qui est absolument
indispensable mais prenez ce fameux
libre-échange ruiné le pays andri là bas
leur dire ouvrez vos frontières à nos
produits agricoles non ferme les
frontières à votre migration je suis
désolée la théorie néoclassique quand
elle dit la spécialisation le libre
échange c'est spécial et son seul
avantage comparatif et l'affectation
optimale des ressources ça veut dire
beaucoup de sénégalais chez nous
beaucoup d'haïtiens aux états unis
qu'est ce que c'est que c'était un
projet d'accord avec ça avant d'y ouvrir
les échanges agricoles et on met des
barrières à la frontière il faut être
très gras il nous faut négocier
effectivement le droit des peuples à
vivre et travailler dignement au pays et
de nourriture leur population au moins
pour les produits de première nécessité
pourquoi n'y aurait-il pas ce droit et
on parle sans arrêt dead faudrait
conserver son droit des peuples merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nouveau marc
dufumier merci à vous jean martin à
vauvert devait d'avoir été avec nous en
direct de bratislava merci alexandre
kateb merci à vous jean marc daniel et
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi
reste avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]
b